olivier schneider président de l'afub la
fédération des usagers de la bicyclette
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france là le gouvernement
insistait pour que ce confinement
hybride prennent en considération le
moral des français notamment en
autorisant les activités sportives
beaucoup plus que lors des deux premiers
confinement on imagine que c'est
d'autant plus dur à accepter pour vous
alors tout à fait faut rappeler que les
magasins de vélos et les réparateurs de
cycle on a toujours déploré les la
communication gouvernementale notamment
pendant le premier confinement des
magasins de cycles avaient le droit
d'être ouverts mais comme personne
n'était au courant finalement ils ont
eux-mêmes fermé parce que personne ne
venait les voir c'était un peu pareil
pendant le second confinement est là
depuis les nouvelles mesures en fait les
magasins de vélo ont le droit d'être
ouverts mais par les magasins de sport
ce qui pose des problèmes
si vous avez un magasin multi sportif
décathlon vous pouvez l'ouvrir mais
uniquement la partie qui traite le cycle
ce qui n'a pas de sens économique et
donc en effet alors que beaucoup de nos
concitoyens considèrent notamment le
vélo comme un geste barrières pour ne
pas créer de la congestion dans les
transports en commun pour ne pas pour
lui avec sa voiture
eh bien on se retrouve à avoir des
difficultés pour entretenir sa
bicyclette et ça a peu de sens alors
qu'on sait que à l'extérieur le risque
de contamination est maîtrisé et que
surtout avoir d'activité physique c'est
bon pour la santé et même pour justement
lutter contre les différentes maladies
et donc oui quelles sont donc les
justifications
donnez l'exécutif pour interdire les
magasins de sport ne pas ouvrir
je ne suis pas le porte parole du
gouvernement
globalement chaque j'imagine que chaque
tranche de commerçants fait son
plaidoyer ou sur le bli pour expliquer
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont essentiels
et donc bien que ce gouvernement et fait
un certain nombre de choses vraiment à
saluer sur le vélo depuis depuis
plusieurs années depuis depuis ses 4 ans
sur le sport en général
malheureusement il ya il s'est considéré
j'en sais rien que les français ont déjà
leur matériel ou autre mais
malheureusement c'est incompréhensible
compte tenu de tous les bienfaits de
l'activité physique pour la santé
physique mais aussi pour la santé
mentale
alors est-ce que vous avez une idée des
conséquences chiffrées du manque à
gagner depuis que les magasins de sport
sont fermées alors le sur le vélo on a
eu une année exceptionnelle serre que il
ya eu une énorme perte sur mars avril
2001 et ça a été rattrapé par les mois
suivants par contre c'est vraiment
spécifique uniquement aux vélos sur tous
les autres sur tous les autres articles
de sport c'est c'est une baisse très
considérable les chiffres seront publiés
dans quelques semaines donc je n'ai
malheureusement pas de chiffre précis
mais c'est vraiment quelque chose que
les professionnels que l'on fréquente
calais schille d'hécatombe et comme déjà
ce domaine est touchée aussi par l'année
blanche à la montagne enfin c'est vrai
que ces professionnels là ne comprennent
pas pourquoi
pourquoi autant de considération pour
d'autres commerces dits essentiels
pourquoi pas pour ceux du sport oui
c'est vrai que certains dénonçant ce
qu'ils appellent à en deux poids deux
mesures est ce que vous êtes quand même
optimiste pour la suite
à moi je pense que vu l'appétence des
français ça fait douze points qu'on a
très répétitivité physique donc et on
voit dès que les cadets confinement dès
qu'il ya des brèches les gens font du
jogging font du vélo et donc je suis je
suis convaincu que avec la couverture
vaccinale ou avec et avec la négociation
avec le gouvernement en effet les
français pourront avoir leurs activités
physiques et les commerces de sport
qu'il faudra soutenir pourront reprendre
activités j'espère au plus olivier
schneider merci à vous d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'afub la fédération des
usagers de la bicyclette martial